foreign
starts this hour in Boston hey Chris how
are you
great how's it going Dave better than we
deserve what's up
hey so really appreciate you taking my
call I uh over the last four years I
entered a job wherein I was able to
make commission checks and save up quite
a nice bit of money and I just am
looking to get your advice having
recently started your program and you
see what I should do with the money I
have and any future money that I get
so are you setting aside is I'm guessing
this is 1099 type money
no this is so I work in Enterprise sales
I get commissions that get taxed at a 35
percent
um I think I take home the 65 so are you
on a budget
I am not on a budget per se I uh I
basically I have my three to six month
emergency fund already done so I have
15K
set aside and I currently have 60 000 in
my savings account and I'm expecting a
hundred and fifty thousand in July from
a deal that I just closed very good so
uh are you renting are you interested in
purchasing a house let's think about
what the next steps are absolutely so
I'm renting I definitely am looking in
the next year or so to start getting
into the housing market
um and the only debt that I currently
have outside of that potential mortgage
is 38 000 in student loans okay and I
know that I need to wipe that out yeah
you could do that with the 60k that's
sitting around the extra 60k you could
do that today yeah yep I know not good
will right
Chris the nervous laugh makes me cringe
don't be nervous laughter you have sixty
thousand dollars write a check today and
pay off get it done do it right now
right now they're not going to get
forgiven is not a pet she's an evil
woman thanks
[Music]
and this is real it's not going to get
forgiven pay it off and then move on
with your life move on with your life
and then let's start thinking about how
old are you
I'm 32. you've done a really good job
Chris okay uh any problem what are you
what would you say the probability is
that you are married in the next 24 to
36 months
I would say it's on a lower end okay all
right so there's not like a there's not
like a thing in the offing that I'm not
talking about yet okay all right cool uh
in that case buy a house now what I
would tell you is buy a home as a single
guy in uh at your age that is not a uh a
specialty home buy a home that's a
little bit vanilla boring easy to resell
because if you were to get married you
will discover you have bought the wrong
home
okay she's going to make you move okay
exactly yeah that I I agree
wholeheartedly with Dave's advice don't
buy you know this perfect home that you
think it's great that you're thinking oh
one of these days I was very relating
it's going to be our family home no no
he's exactly right whoever you marry
she's gonna go if you guys let's do
something else exactly if you can resell
it easily you'll make a lot of money on
it
and that's what I want you to buy for
your first one here and your stage of
life in your current demographic and
everything that's what I would do if I
were your age but you're doing great man
the obvious thing is you're making a lot
of money and you've not been crazy with
it uh so pay off your student loan have
your emergency fund earmark everything
Beyond three to six months of expenses
for your down payment pile up a huge
down payment don't take out more than a
15-year fixed where the payment is more
than a fourth of your take-home pay and
buy something that's a little bit
vanilla not too fancy schmancy and it's
going to be easy to resell it's going to
have a large Market when you get ready
to resell it a lot of people are going
to want this property which will make it
go up faster and easier to sell both
that's what the the summation of this
call is so very very well done
wow he did good he did do good he's got
a lot of money coming in a lot of Cash
Money serious bucks